another star who knows what it's like to
put your whole life out there is Britney
Spears right now she is hotter than ever
with a brand new song and you were gonna
get to hear it because she's sharing it
with us first it's the rebirth of
Britney Spears with her new song private
show it seems like the star is going in
a very mature and different direction
private show is inevitably a sexy song
the fresh track shares a name with her
new perfume hi everyone it's Britney and
we were behind the scenes as she shot
the commercial and the 34 year old star
looks phenomenal and is dancing like we
haven't seen her do in years sources say
the song will be on Britney's ninth
studio album which she's been working on
for almost two years well I'm just I'm
taking it really slow Petey is
practically the same age as Britney and
we have been with the pop icon from the
very beginning of her career back in
2014 she told us she was creating a
brand new sound it's not so teeny bopper
a little bit more of a rock feel to it
she hinted at her love of rock with her
2002 cover up I love rock and roll but
judging by what she says is the
inspiration for her new sound the days
of pigtails red jumpsuits and sweaty
belly dancing may truly be behind her it
really is this is different more
different than I've ever done the mom of
two has been rebuilding her empire since
setting up shop on the Vegas trip last
fall she extended her Planet Hollywood
contract for two more years with a
reported 35 million dollar price tag I'm
all about work right now and main thing
is to enjoy life and take one day at a
time and I try to live by that